the liar's punishment is that even when
he speaks the truth no one believes him
[Music]
life's not as good with money as it is
bad without it
adam was the first lucky man as he had
no mother-in-law
if a problem can be solved with money
then it's not a problem but a cost
god gave man two ears and one mouth so
listen more and talk less
[Music]
may god protect you from bad people and
save yourself from good ones
god cannot be everywhere at once that's
why he created mothers
be not sweet or else you'll be eaten be
not bitter or else you'll be spat out
fear a goat in front of you a horse
behind you and a fool all around
a guest and a fish start reeking on the
third day
knowledge does not take much space
better a jew without a beard than a
beard without a jew
a man should live at least for curiosity
a deaf man heard a dumb man recount that
a blind man saw a lame one run very fast
god protect the poor at least from
expensive sins
[Music]
if charity was worth nothing everyone
would be philanthropists
when an old maiden marries she becomes a
young wife
parents teach their children to talk
children teach their parents silence
all people are good from afar
eggs may be much cleverer than chickens
but they go rotten too quickly
keeping good silence is harder than
talking good
[Music]
a bad partner is worse than rain the
latter makes you go home while the
former makes you go outside
[Music]
the world will not disappear because
there are many people but because there
are too many non-people
god help me rise to my feet a fall is
what i can do myself
[Music]
if life doesn't change for the better
wait and it will change for the worse
however sweet love may be you can't make
a stew out of it
when people have nothing to do they take
up great deeds
choosing between two evils a pessimist
picks both
[Music]
everyone complains about a lack of money
but none complain about a lack of brains
who doesn't have children brings them at
best
[Music]
it's better to die of laughter than of
fear
experience is the word people use to
call their mistakes
being gray of hair means you're simply
old not wise
[Music]
growing old man's sight worsens but this
allows him to see more
act the way you'd like to be and soon
you'll be the way you act
everything we do in life is based on
fear especially love
[Music]
our heads around so thought can change
direction
[Music]
we can endure much more than we think we
can all human experience testifies to
that
[Music]
only a life live for others is a life
worthwhile
our lives no longer belong to us alone
they belong to all those who need us
desperately
do not wait until the conditions are
perfect to begin
beginning makes the conditions perfect
[Music]
a righteous man falls down seven times
and gets up
the highest form of wisdom is kindness
do not say something that should never
be heard because ultimately it will be
heard
do not separate yourself from the
community
act while you can while you have the
chance the means and the strength
the world is a dark place for one who
looks to the table of others
[Music]
we cannot solve our problems with the
same thinking we used when we created
them
[Music]
to make a woman want to have sex with
you the first thing you need to do is
make her feel sexually attracted to you
[Music]
[Music]
you